ah c'est toute la gaule était envahie
par les armées de promoteurs c'est ici
que subsisterait le dernier village
d'irréductibles ou plutôt la dernière
courait à savoir l'impasse ville à
wazemmes havre de paix que la vingtaine
de locataires tient à défendre car le
propriétaire une société immobilière
parisienne cherchent à vendre l'ensemble
ce n'est pas une bataille pour pouvoir
profiter d'un lieu mais c'est une
bataille pour le lieu c'est à dire que
le lieu mieux perdure jusqu'à jusqu'à ce
qu'on ne soit plus la soutenir dans deux
ans sera dans cinq ans dix ans et des
gens qu'ils ont pu repartir donc qui
vont arriver et c'est ce qu'on veut
c'est le dernier et seul endroit une
dernière en droit à lille oui on pouvait
le bâtiment de mettre au fond tout comme
une mixité sociale qui a fait l'âme des
cours et car une banque écossaise est
intéressé et qui dit investisseurs dit
recherche de bénéfices et loyers
prohibitifs
heureusement la communauté urbaine a
entendu la voix des locataires combatif
et regroupés au sein d'une association
la métropole est utilisé son droit de
préemption pour acquérir la cour et les
dossiers vont être étudiées famille par
famille en fonction de leur situation
familiale sociale financière de manière
à regarder les conditions d'habitat tout
comme chaque maison individuellement va
être revu au niveau de sa réinstallation
technique et ses mises aux normes
d'habitabilité et laisser les locataires
dans leurs murs reste que la banque
écossaise est prêt à payer le double du
prix proposé par lille métropole saisit
de la sphère le juge de l'expropriation
a reporté sa décision pourrait examiner
le dossier femmes